the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show i
know a lot of people are going to email
me about the youtube situation i think
calling it a crisis is not crazy and so
you know if there are specific questions
from people who are already members and
they want me to address that in more
detail on the bonus show in the next
couple of days I'm glad to just let me
know you know what your questions are
different people have been writing in
with different suggestions about things
that could be done we're looking at
everything and you know like I said Pat
my goal is that some significant portion
of the youtube revenue recovers and that
then there's a much smaller gap that we
need to make up but it's now been thirty
first first second third it's been four
days and basically there are not ads
running on our videos it is possible
that by this time next week everything
could go back to normal or YouTube could
have a new ad system where if not a
hundred percent of the revenue is
replaced maybe sixty seventy percent
optimistically that's optimistic which
is really unfortunate but worst case
scenario this continues yeah worst case
scenario this is the new normal and then
listen then we need to figure out well
what what's the path forward without
YouTube and that's something we'll have
no choice but to do okay one thing I do
want to mention is if there's something
in the immediate that you're you have
some graphic design skills and want to
help us with we are looking to do we're
looking to start putting out on social
media good quotes from the show from the
previous day's show and so we want to
get some nice sort of quote backgrounds
where there would probably be some
combination of either like one of the
cartoons of me or a picture of me and
the show's logo and then some box area
where we could overlay text and these
can do really well like on Instagram and
Twitter and Facebook etc we just don't
have those background graphics so if you
want to develop some of these quote
graphics for us that would be really
great yeah I think that's a great idea
because oftentimes either you or I will
say something that's quite memorable
right and then you'll look at say the
YouTube comments
and the top rated comment is a quote
directly from us because it's just
become immortalized yes so I think that
that's a real real opportunity so the
again the only restrictions would be we
wanted to be 1920 x 1080 in terms of
resolution it should include some
combination of a graphic or picture of
our logo and then I've got a bunch of
pictures of me also but cartoon versions
and different stuff we would ideally
have like four or five of these that we
could rotate so if you want any of the
source graphics to layer on to whatever
you're thinking of email me david at
david pakman.com if you want to just
pull graphics off the web initially to
sort of mock something up and then you
know you can email it to me and then i
can send back some of the higher res
graphics i'm glad to do that but we
would like to have four or five of these
to be able to rotate and just a new way
in which will be able to promote what we
do we've got audio and video it would be
great to have some visual things to
promote and there's plenty of things
that you can look at to inspire you to
so for example there's plenty of cartoon
images of david including from the most
recent calendar and at the time you know
I was quite upset that I was not
featured in the calendar and right who
informed maybe this would be a chance to
make my mark too yes that that could we
never know when that's going to pop up
and I'm sure when it does it will be a
combination of interesting funny and
traumatic in some way hopefully it's not
it's flattering you know hopefully not
too bad a few things that well actually
I don't even want to say I can think of
some themes that people might include in
cartoon versions of you related to
discussions on the show but I won't
mention them just to not influence
people's creativity all right yeah I
like that idea and this is all words and
quotes that i would say rather than just
strictly the cartoon form of me yes
absolutely no doubt about okay let's
talk about every once in a while we get
a does the punishment fit the crime sort
of story and usually somebody ends up
upset even some somebody either someone
ends up upset because they feel that one
or all of us are being too light about
what the sentence should be or too
strong about what the sentence should be
this story is about a man who
intentionally sorbed into a couple on a
motorcycle in hood county causing them
to crash and injure themselves this was
about a year
and a half ago he has been sentenced to
15 years in prison according to his
attorney has confirmed late last week
we're talking about William Sam Crum a
69 year old man who was roughly sixty
seven at the time of this incident
convicted on two counts of aggravated
assault with a deadly weapon in a jury
trial he has been in jail since his
arrest back in October of 2015 he was
accused of purposely swerving into a
Kawasaki motorcycle on tin top highway
causing the motorcyclists 37 year old
eric sanders to crash there's a video of
the incident which has been floating
around which went completely viral when
this happened and it shows the
motorcycle from behind speeding up to
pass crumbs car on a two-lane road and
Crum suddenly swerves across the painted
dividing lines and clips the bike
causing it and the two bikers who were
on the bike to fall and slide along the
pavement and Sanders is seen in the
video getting up almost immediately and
limping towards the road he somehow
ended up with only minor injuries
although his passenger Deborah Simpson
was motionless on her back in rodeo that
went viral broken arms great bruises she
ended up in the intensive care unit in
Texas and 15 years for this what do you
think does that strike you as too high
to low or just right for the crime well
I mean a car is something that can
easily kill someone and yet sometimes we
get desensitized to that because many of
us are driving every single day but
absolutely seems like he doesn't even
have a good defense for this he said I
don't care what is the difference that
you use when you really have no counter
argument and the other thing you said
was well it wouldn't have happened if
they hadn't illegally passed me as if
that gives you justification for let's
say someone's jaywalking and you punched
him in the face that's right how these
things work there's one other aspect to
his defense which is he did say they
were passing on a no passing zone and
that's why the crash happened which
isn't really true it happened because he
decided to swerve out of the lane he was
also breaking the law by Pat right if
they had broken the law by passing the
the the double yellow line in no passing
zone he did the exact same thing but he
claims it was because he had a spider
bite which
caused him to momentarily lose control
of the vehicle right before the car
accident now you knew what he was doing
people get upset whenever cars pass them
or motorcycles past them especially if
you're stuck in traffic and someone just
wants to drive down the shoulder and go
past everyone yeah and you know this
affects me too sometimes I'll be upset
if someone cuts me off but what it's a
motorcycle I don't really seem to care
because why should they have to wait
behind me my car is so much bigger right
I mean they are breaking the law when
they start doing that thing where
they're going down the the shoulder
swerving between cars but it's not
really my it's not affecting me in any
way it's not somebody with a car who
thinks that they can just cut everybody
who's already been waiting it's a
different situation I guess when what
would the penalty for that be just a
small ticket or something about you can
take justice into your own hands no no
no cause them irreparable damage so I
think that 15 years is harsh but I think
it's within the confines of what I would
call fitting the crime or commensurate
with the crime particularly when you
think of these two people could have
ended up dead and the fact that they
didn't merely because of the exact
moment and angle at which the motorcycle
was clipped should not be completely
exculpatory obviously if they had died
15 years probably would not be enough
for somebody who took this action but I
think I mean you somebody who is willing
to act this way on the roads is a danger
to society no doubt yeah I can see why
prosecutors would seek out 15 years but
there's plenty of mitigating
circumstances which likely fighter by
leave yeah like maybe he did actually
have a spider bite or you know he's 69
years old so you put him in jail for 15
years he could very likely die in prison
but also there's more aggravating
circumstances like the fact that he has
a criminal history he has a criminal
history if he probably wouldn't spend 15
years because you know with good
behavior and overcrowding and I'm
guessing that this is going to be
considered sort of nonviolent in the
grand scheme of things compared to some
other people in terms of parole
availability so he may well end up in
there for four years or something like
that yeah we'll see if he shows any
remorse and backs off of this spider
bite story yet you have to care about
this sort of thing yeah it's uh it's a
it's a story that any one of us could be
deliberately targeted on the road in
this way luckily
I don't drive a motorcycle yeah I used
to used to but not anymore a former
Florida Governor Jeb Bush said over the
weekend that people should be marching
in the streets to demand changes to
antiquated education systems that are
not preparing students to be competitive
in the job market against the robots of
the future this is Jeb Bush fo saying
quote the looming challenge of
automation and AI and the rapid
advancement of technology brings great
benefits but also creates huge
challenges Hillary Clinton didn't want
to talk about it Donald Trump didn't
want to talk about it it was just a race
to say who could who could claim that
they would be bringing back jobs that no
longer exist in a more appealing way and
the truth was a lot of those jobs were
gone then they are gone now they will
continue to disappear and Jeb Bush you
know that Donald Trump would say that
this is a low-energy statement from Jeb
Bush what he'd say well Oh Jeff's
talking about robots that's low energy
I'm bringing jobs back and that was the
risk that was why no one talked about it
during a campaign because it was a
losing battle even though it was true
well what surprises you more that Jeb
Bush is getting ahead of the curve in
talking about automation and it's
probably one of the few politicians that
is even discussing that at this point
yeah or that Jeb Bush is calling for
riots to happen in the streets or yes
peaceful protests to happen in the
streets I mean that's that's a high
energy sign from Jeb Bush the fact that
he is saying people should be out in the
streets is in and of itself it continued
yeah I'm against these family dynasties
I I when Hillary Clinton was running for
president I said really we we have 330
million people in this country and we
need to have two presidents from the
same family that is that is that really
necessary and I said the same thing with
george w bush and i said the same thing
with Jeb Bush but Jeb Bush was one of
the more reasonable Republicans that was
running and hence why a chance
especially was kind of upsetting in
Hillary Clinton's instance because she
would have been the first woman elected
president and even though she came from
humble beginnings middle class
background it would have been nice I
think if the person the first woman
president was more self made yes rather
than you know she had a husband who was
president so then later 20 years after
she could become herself rather there
are people who will hear you say that
Pat and they will say Pat you're being
disrespectful to Hillary Clinton because
she was self made in the sense that she
went to law
school and got herself a lot of great
law degree with accessible attorney uh
she ran for Senate although would she
have been a likely candidate for Senate
had she not been first lady I think
there's something fair there but their
little super political as first lady
because she pushed universal health care
there are people who will hear you say
that and say you're sort of writing off
her accomplishments in some way I don't
think that's the case I think any
objective observer would say if it
weren't for george HW bush george w bush
would have been very unlikely to become
president of the united states he barely
became president of the united states as
it is and i think the same thing applies
to Hillary Clinton it doesn't mean she
wouldn't have had a worthwhile and
notable career regardless but she was in
the position she was in because of being
Secretary of State which happened in
part because she was a senator which
happened in part because she was so well
known on the national stage because of
being a first lady right that's why I
made those statement that same went with
so many qualifiers because there were a
bunch of different factors in getting
her to the position that she was in yeah
but you have to look at the overarching
factor the fact that Bill Clinton was
her husband and in a country of 300
million people there's going to be
plenty of successful women with law
degrees and working for the Children's
Defense Fund that kind of work and
everything else no doubt but the thing
that sticks out was that her husband was
also president I I agree with it I agree
with you and anyway back to what we were
saying Jeb Bush he's absolutely right
he's absolutely right we've got to talk
more about automation and technological
unemployment that conversation naturally
gets us to a conversation about basic
income a guaranteed basic income we've
talked about the many experiments that
are going on around the world over a
dozen I think at this point into that
and you know by not talking about it
we're not going to avoid the problem
will just be less prepared to solve it
as it gets worse and worse so if it's a
Republican whether he's a low-energy
Republican or a high-energy Republican I
don't care whoever is willing to talk
about this I'm willing to listen yeah
it's not even necessarily a disaster too
because people working less as long as
they're compensated in another form like
a universal basic income would allow
them to pursue their more creative
interests sure and you know have a
better work-life balance and perhaps
live a more fulfilling life than just
you
working 60 70 hours a week and there may
be sort of intangible or associated
societal benefits to that so it's not
just like climate change or something
that we have to prevent otherwise face
the consequences you know with this as
long as we get ahead of it we could be
well prepared and it could end up
turning out quite well yes all of those
things are possible however it doesn't
actually seem we're going in that
direction it seems we're basically for
the most part burying our heads in the
sand burying and politicians any way of
presenting that this isn't an issue
which is you know what dads ! low energy
is done all right that's it for today's
bonus show we'll be back the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]